por tercer día consecutivo se vuelve a
hablar de corredores humanitarios en
ucrania hay civiles que en estos
momentos están abandonando la zona de
espn a pocos kilómetros de civiles que
están siendo evacuados tras que rusia y
ucrania llegarán a un acuerdo para al
cese al fuego esta noticia llega después
de los fracasos del fin de semana
fracasos que han visto afectada a la
ciudad sureña de mariupol donde no se ha
podido producir una evacuación completa
a raíz de que la ambas partes no han
podido llegar a un acuerdo sobre el cese
al fuego y todo esto ocurre en un
momento en el que putin sigue afirmando
que quiere tomar todo el país y selenski
que en aquellos que ha bombardeado a
ucrania pagarán muy fuertemente lo que
han hecho
se trata de un contexto complicado en el
que sin embargo tanto china como la
unión europea se están ofreciendo
nuevamente como mediadores para alcanzar
finalmente una solución a este conflicto
que empezó ya hace dos semanas